north Korea has been accused of
preparing a rocket launch according to
US officials the Americans say there is
evidence of increased activity at the so
high satellite launching station and
earlier this month North Korea conducted
a fourth nuclear test we're joined now
by Robert Kelley associate professor in
the Department of Political Science and
diplomacy at Pusan National University
in South Korea's so thank you very much
for joining us at what is the evidence
that America are touting in this case
well as you said there is increased
activity at the site itself right
there's an Erector site the erector has
been expanded in the last couple of
years there's been sort of development
around the site is increasing traffic
it's also the case that around nuclear
tests to know the fourth nuclear test
was a month ago the North Koreans have
often preceded that with ballistic
missile launch and so now people are
saying well maybe they reversed or
something like that but often these
things going Candice oh my guess is
that's the reason I that's the logic but
in effect I mean this is him throwing up
two fingers if you will here in the UK
to the international community because
there are sanctions that have been put
in place after the nuclear test and
Pyongyang just seems to be ignoring them
yeah that's great the North Koreans are
already pretty heavily sanctioned right
so it's easy for the North Korean
sasural go further because the North
Koreans actually have already carried a
lot of the pain there's big argument
about whether or not we can sanction
them further I actually do believe that
it's great deal more that we can do but
so long as China defends them
particularly China defends North Korea's
money then it's really alert for further
sanctions to actually bite deep right so
as long as china is behind for blocking
sanctions or inhibiting their expansion
then it's easy for North Koreans to keep
running and that's what get that's
what's going on here right i think the
North Koreans say you know we saw with
the Americans did in Iraq and Libya and
if we don't have her own nuclear weapons
and missiles will be the subject of a
regime change the salt or something like
that later and so we have to have these
things that's the argument they make and
they've been saying that for 20 years so
China is the key here but is there any
way that the international community can
put pressure on China to put pressure on
Pyongyang yeah that's really the big
discussion right now there's actually a
very wide-ranging debate on this right
now my own sense is yes that you're
correct that china is the key the
Chinese resent this enormously if you
follow Chinese media every time the
North Koreans do something outrageous
you know we hear a lot from the Chinese
about how will we know we can't stop
them we can
man Chinese media really dislikes this
debate but this is also a little bit
going to take off Asia it's no longer
the United States alone that is
insisting that China has leverage over
North Korea the South Koreans are saying
this as well South Korea has invested a
lot of time and effort in the last three
or four years to bring China around and
then the North Koreans won't often did
this test anyway so I think to a certain
extent you know the Chinese are looking
at a choice here do they want to
continue to support North Korea or do
they want to get along with the
neighbors they have in Asia a lot of
whom don't want North Korean nuclear
weapons either South Korea Japan Taiwan
a lot of courage in Asia don't want
North Korea have nuclear weapons either
and this is good because this is
increasingly forcing China to make a
choice between standing with North Korea
we're getting along with the
neighborhood and that expands a
discussion from simply just the United
States versus China if that's how it's
praying the Chinese will never bunch
just finally you're living in south
korea i mean how nervous two people get
in the country whenever there is a spite
like this I'm actually not that much um
this is something when I first moved
career like you know 10 years ago or so
I actually felt the same way I thought
you know all North Korean nuclear test
notes look terrifying South Koreans have
actually long since adjusted themselves
that actually I would argue a bit too
much I don't think South Koreans
actually take the North Korean threat as
seriously as they should but South
Koreans have been living with this like
I said for 20 years the nuclear North
Korea's had a nuclear bomb now for 12 13
years and the South Koreans of X I
actually find that deal with it rather
well I mean like I said I wish they'd
actually worried about it more i'd like
to see South Koreans for example take
missile defense a little bit more
seriously South Korea needs a roof it
doesn't really have one against missile
assault but the South Korean show quite
calm about it Robert Kelley associate
professor in the Department of Political
Science and diplomacy at Pusan National
University in South Korea thank you very
much